[Musique]
la magie à la fois sublime et puissante
et le lien qui unifie notre long passé
ce lien que nous partageons tout ça est
l'héritage de poudlard
[Applaudissements]
temps aujourd'hui de bâtir votre propre
histoire dans ce lieu médias
et peut-être même de façonner le futur
du mot
haut de dix ans
chaque couloir chaque portrait chaque
pierre de ce château raconte l'histoire
des sorciers et des sorcières qui
étaient là avant
ici vous vous ferez des amis pour la vie
et développerez vos compétences en magie
dans les salles de classe des
professeurs les plus talentueux tandis
que vous entamerez votre aventure à
poudlard concoctant des ponts sont dont
temps des animaux fantastiques
et pratiquant des sorts
plus faste s'ouvrira au delà de ces
rempli de dangers que vous n'osez
imaginer un savoir anciens disparus
depuis fort longtemps de ce monde
c'est un nom étrange et mystérieux que
vous possédez et peut-être la clé qui
vous permettra de développer ce pouvoir
endormi
votre potentiel
[Musique]
et une limité
mais quelle forme prendra cure
[Musique]
aventure qui vous attend
révélera quels sont vos véritables
valeurs
[Musique]
les choix que vous ferez
définiront l'héritage
de poudlard